[Musique]
12 qui 50 points et un maul keith la
nouvelle tendance sportive et où la
france brille en juillet 2010 est elle
est devenue championne d'europe de la
discipline
alors mesdames il dit c'est un sport
khémisset un sport qui a été inventé
dans le grand nord en finlande dans les
années 90 c'est un jeu d'adressé entre
la pétanque et le bowling et vous avez
déjà fait une rapide présentation il ya
bien 12 qui les 50 points c'est le score
à atteindre pour gagner la partie
mes attentes attention 50 points tout
pile pas plus par mois et le maul qui
s'est tout simplement le nom du lanceur
un bâton en bois
le reste des explications c'est avec
thibaut durand le président d'un club
tout récent installé à montigny hors
auto 9 g qui composait de 1 à 12 vont
d'abord être éclaté au départ donc on va
devoir établir un cassé pour éparpiller
les qui l'est qui vont après être
relevés à l'endroit où il tombe est en
fête
les points sont comptés
de différentes façons soit en fait tombé
qu'une seule qui en gagnent le nombre de
points qui a indiqué sur l'acquis donc
si on fait trouver là qui 12 on gagne 12
points mais par contre si on fait tomber
plusieurs qui on va compter le nom de
qik est tombé par terre donc sélection
fait tomber trois quilles on gagne que
trois points alors au môle qui il faut
donc de la drees pour bien viser les
kings mais aussi de la tactique de la
tactique et ça permet aussi pourquoi pas
de faire des mathématiques de manière
ludique puisqu'il faut s'y trouver
comment gagner le plus de points pour
atteindre les fameux 50 points ça peut
se jouer en équipe
à chaque tour on redresse les qui chaque
joueur à trois essais pour viser les
quilles si vous avez trois pc
l'immunisation
alors si on voulait jouer ou est ce
qu'on peut en trouver tout simplement
dans les diverses boutiques de jouets
j'ai navigué sur les sites de plusieurs
enseignes prix qu'ils ont et qui sont
présentes en france les prix aussi entre
20 et 50 euros en fonction des boutiques
et je connais de la qualité des morceaux
une fois acheté ne vous reste plus qu'à
trouver un terrain plat et dégagé et à
vous amuser surtout pour en découvrir un
peu plus aussi n'hésitez pas à aller sur
le site internet de la fédération
française
merci mélanie alors on